gentlemen how are you doing what's up i
literally talked to you last week
and i also talked to jeffrey recently
for what if so um i see you guys more
than some of my friends and i say that's
awesome
i want to start with congratulations on
the movie uh this is what we call a
great film and that's all i have i'll
see you guys later thank you peace
great interview
um so jeffrey i think this is your third
bond billy this is your first i'm just
i'm just curious
what do you think would surprise people
to learn about the making of a james
bond film that maybe they wouldn't
expect
no one knows what they're doing
[Laughter]
okay
that's it
i know the community the community the
the the bonds that are literally built
and like uh the excitement of showing up
to work every day it's so
so enriching
uh for me it was
i i i dig working on these movies
because you know you you kind of see the
same faces not just in front of the
camera but behind the cameras the crew
um very loyal to these projects you know
you've got guys who've been working on
these films for decades who come back
you know time and again so it's a it's a
really
you know despite it being you know
people think what we do is
you know there's all the glamour and the
glitz and all that stuff and there's an
element of that but
the work is about something much simpler
it's really about coming together yes in
pretty cool locations and all that but
it's about coming together with a group
of people group of hard-working people
uh you know just grinding it out and in
this case it's a family of people that
stick together over time and that's um
it makes it you know makes it that much
easier um uh you know once you once you
get on board but it also just gives it
this familial quality that's pretty cool
uh billy i'm curious how much were you
[ __ ] bricks the night before your
first day of filming when you're getting
ready to actually go film a bond movie
or did it not even get in your head at
all
i i definitely wasn't [ __ ] bricks i
was like
i was like really uh
feel it i felt really comfortable again
i knew jeffrey before from game night
and then uh i felt very comfortable
working with carrie because i worked
with him on maniac
so
yeah i wasn't
nervous at all i was more excited like
he was super hyped i was yeah i was
pumped i was like let's go
like
yeah i i again it was a treat
sure uh jeffrey i'm curious when did you
actually know you were coming back and
how early on in like the scripting proc
like
because you know there's i guess what
i'm curious about is how early on did
you know you were coming back and uh uh
what happens if you say no or what
happens if your schedule doesn't allow
you to be part of the film because you
know your character is a critical part
yeah well they you know if i say no they
say hey we're going to make this bond
movie we want to fly you down to jamaica
for for you know for a couple of weeks
to uh to hang out film surf um drink
you know uh ray and nephew um
it's hard for me to you know jerk
chicken and pork it's hard for me to say
no to that you know
um so
uh if i had said no i probably would
have to check myself but at the same
time i was working on westworld
uh and they were uh very accommodating
to me uh to let me go away for a little
bit
and come down and join in uh you know
with everybody so um it took you know it
took a little bit of coordinating and uh
and i'm glad uh glad it worked out you
know yeah i mean
every time there's another bond film out
barbara broccoli who is you know
are guiding absolutely wonderful like
you know she clues me in that okay
you know felix is in the script uh okay
he's not in the script now you know
she'll like send up a flare to me
and uh on this one uh yeah he's uh he's
there i'm glad he's back you know to
round out you know the uh
the the arc for uh for the character and
i'm glad i was there at the start uh
with daniel and and now at the end so
um yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't have said
no to this uh you know i hopped on uh
you know i hopped on board as uh as soon
as the invitation was sent
yeah i think it was i was my thing was
more about scheduling because i know
you're you're you know very busy but i
gotta go um i just wanna say again
congratulations to you guys and have a
fantastic day thank you thank you